salve a tutti
parto dai paesaggi quelli agricoli sono
forse i più comuni che possiamo vedere
nella nostra quotidianità soprattutto
qua nella campagna intorno a torino ci
sono ovviamente familiari e ci serve ci
sembrano del tutto naturali però se ci
fermiamo un attimo a osservarli anche un
semplice orto ci accorgiamo che sono
geometrici sono puliti sono molto
ordinati le piante sono distanziate
perfettamente l'una dall'altra sono ben
fertilizzati e sono ben irrigati e anche
se marketing e pubblicità ci associano
parole come naturale sostenibilità
biologico
la domanda sorge spontanea se
l'agricoltura può essere definita
naturale
facciamo un piccolo gioco vi faccio
vedere delle piante prima e dopo la cura
della dell'agricoltura
la prima è abbastanza semplice credo che
tutti voi possiate riconoscere in questa
una melanzana anche se la pianta di
partenza in realtà una pianta ricca di
semi al limite del mangiabile molto
amara e ricca di solanina che è un
alcaloide molto velenoso che costringe
anche oggi giorno a cucinare le
melanzane prima di consumarli passa al
secondo esempio sapere che piante questa
no questa è l'antenata della carota
anche se sarebbe più corretto fare
questa animazione qua con un passaggio
verso il
il viola per poi arrivare all'arancione
perché come credo tutti sappiate
l'arancione è stato selezionato nel 1600
dagli olandesi in onore della della
corona del del proprio paese ma davanti
questa pianta sapete cos'è questa è un
cavolo
anzi è brassica oleracea che ha generato
non una ma tutte queste tante qua che
noi che non abbiamo visto ma sono tutti
di fatto i cavoli che conosciamo e
consumiamo quotidianamente questa forse
la più difficile di tutte e è l'antenato
oil teosinte l'antenato del del mais
quindi abbiamo una netta
contrapposizione fra natura e
agricoltura un campo incolto e un campo
coltivato una raccolta di frutti
selvatici è una raccolta di frutti
coltivati oppure una pianta come abbiamo
visto il teosinte e la sua versione
agricola proprio il mais ci dà l'idea di
come
sia stata radicale la trasformazione fra
le piante selvatiche e le piante
coltivate
se guardate il raffronto da vicino vi
rendete conto che le differenze non sono
da poco se andiamo ad analizzare le
piante la pianta originale e il mais
ci rendiamo conto che il teosinte è una
pianta bassa piccola con steli multipli
mentre il mais è una stella unico con
poche infiorescenze se dovessimo
coltivare quest'ultimo senza il nostro
ausilio sarebbe una pianta molto
svantaggiata perché non riuscirebbe a
disperdere i semi come fa il suo
antenato ma di contro per l'uomo è un
vantaggio perché la raccolta in questo
modo è molto avvantaggiata perché un
ostello solo poche pannocchie aiutano
l'uomo nella raccolta ancora se andiamo
ad analizzare la pianta originaria
vediamo che fa tante piccole pannocchie
con pochissimi semi viceversa la
selezione che abbiamo scelto noi con dei
geni modificati abbiamo portato avanti
fa sì che il mais produca 2 barra 3 di
media parlò chi è ricchissima e di semi
di nuovo spostarsi dovessimo spostare
dalla pianta in natura
questa avrebbe di nuovo problemi perché
i semi cadrebbero tutti nella stessa
posizione e le piante che nascerebbero
andrebbero ovviamente in competizione
non nascendo non crescendo in maniera
ottimale di nuovo però per l'uomo è un
vantaggio non in dubbio perché facilita
di nuovo la raccolta con pochi e
pannocchie ricchissime di semi grandi
siamo siamo avvantaggiati nella raccolta
per ultimo il teosinte il seme del
presente possiede una foglia modificata
che chiamiamo blu ma che avvolge e
protegge il seme la prima è pressoché è
sparita nel nel mais che coltiviamo nel
mais moderno
di nuovo sottoposta alla selezione
naturale la pianta avrebbe seri problemi
perché il seme in questo modo non
supererebbe l'apparato digerente degli
animali uccelli in primis e sarebbe
veramente un problema per la pianta
riprodursi
per noi è un ulteriore vantaggio perché
possiamo consumare il seme direttamente
senza fare lavorazione vada seppero che
dovesse crescere senza del nostro
ausilio questa pianta ormai
tremendamente modificata dalle dalla
selezione che ha fatto nuovo nei secoli
andrebbe incontro a un destino sicuro
potrei andare avanti con con esempi del
genere tutto tutto il giorno mi hanno
detto che un limite di tempo mi limito
solamente un altro esempio è quello del
del mandorlo
se fate un giro in un bosco per
combatterlo selvatico fate molta ma
molta attenzione perché il mandorlo
selvatico al suo interno a una molecola
che si chiama maddalena che è piuttosto
inattiva che però all'interno del nostro
organismo trova un un enzima che la
scinde in tre molecole più piccole
queste molecole sono glucosio
benzaldeide soprattutto acido cianidrico
inutile spiegarvi e cosa significa avere
del cianuro nel nostro organismo
però di nuovo lamenta lina serve a
scoraggiare gli animali a mangiare i
propri semi per poi poter sperare nella
nella nascita di nuove piante tanti
secoli fa uno sconsiderato o un genio ha
selezionato una pianta con un gene
modificato che ha di fatto non fa più
produrre alla pianta il la migdal in a
ovviamente in questa pianta non avrebbe
avuto speranza in natura viceversa sotto
le nostre cure ha permesso di consumare
ad oggi le mandorle che abbiamo chiamato
ovviamente mandorle dolci e quello che
facciamo da quando abbiamo iniziato
addomesticare le piante seleziono
selezioniamo all'inizio inconsciamente
poi sempre più
con coscienza le piante che hanno
determinate caratteristiche che vadano
bene a noi piuttosto che che alle piante
togliamo loro i competitori gli diamo
fertilizzanti e acqua a volontà
e questo fa sì che l'agricoltura si
discosta in maniera radicale dalla dalla
natura almeno come come ce la
immaginiamo
del resto basta leggere una definizione
di agricoltural uno dei qualsiasi
manuali che potete trovare sia online
che in cartaceo per scoprire che questa
di fatto è un'invenzione dell'ingegno
umano sarebbe più corretto dire una
reinvenzione perché questo animaletto
qua la formica coltiva funghi da circa
60 milioni di anni ci ha battuto per per
qualche anno riserva primato a parte
l'agricoltura nata in primis nella
mezzaluna fertile 12 milani e fa poi è
nata spontaneamente anche in altre
epoche in altri luoghi del pianeta
quello che sfugge completamente alla gli
storici e perché abbiamo scelto di
adottare questa nuova forma di
alimentazione lasciando il vecchio
metodo di cacciatori raccoglitori
se infatti andiamo a vedere le gli
scheletri dei primi agricoltori e cira
ci accorgiamo che sono fortemente
segnati da gravi carenze alimentari
questo è andato avanti per millenni
l'altezza media per esempio del popolo
turco molto vicino alle zone della
nascita della dell'agricoltura ci
accorgiamo che ancora oggi ha da
recuperare l'altezza che avevano i loro
antenati prima dell'adozione della della
dell'agricoltura e addirittura se
guardiamo uno degli ultimi popoli che
pratica la raccolta e la caccia ci
accorgiamo come sia ricca la loro dieta
e come poco tempo impieghino per
procurarsi il cibo per un'intera
settimana
poi si fa risalire alla l'agricoltura
anche la nascita delle diseguaglianze
sociali la tirannia da skira la
schiavitù la proprietà privata e anche
la guerra qua ci siamo ci siamo
scatenati con la con la fantasia è
ancora peggio si fa risalire anche la
nascita del pinocchietto per uomo
scherzi scherzi a parte
scherzi a parte dei di rete ma come è
possibile che tutti i mali della della
nostra dell'umanità siano siano
riconducibili a all'agricoltura che mi
sarebbe per esempio di un aspetto
importante della nostra vita come el
arte e tutto quello che abbiamo in
questo senso collezionato nel corso del
tempo possibile rispondere alla domanda
del genere è impossibile sapere come
sarebbero andate le cose se 12.000 anni
fa avessimo preso una strada diversa
è importante però ricordare che pitture
del genere splendide pitture rupestri
che sono presenti in una grotta nelle
grotte in tante grotte francesi
risalgono al 32 mila anni fa quindi il
se volete il germe della creatività e
dell'arte era presente molto prima della
dell'adozione dell'agricoltura e anche
se il percorso a braccetto con
l'agricoltura è solamente una minima
parte di quello che abbiamo intrapreso
da quando 200.000 anni fa è apparsa la
specie homo sapiens
credo sia ormai troppo tardi per i
ripensamenti anche perché non vorrei
essere io a spiegarlo ai vegani
tornando al nostro ragionamento è
interessante guardare come la resa di
un ettaro coltivato a frumento sia
rimasta incredibilmente costante nei
millenni
se andiamo a vedere antichi domani
all'età di carlo magno nel nel
rinascimento ma anche all'inizio del
secolo scorso la la resa era sempre una
tonnellata per ettaro dobbiamo di fatto
aspettare la metà del secolo scorso
quando questo signore norman bob log in
introduce la cosiddetta rivoluzione
verde che valse la vittoria del premio
nobel per la pace per il suo impegno
nella lotta alla fame
cosa fece di fatto bablok inserì
tecnologia fertilizzanti chimici e
fitofarmaci in agricoltura con risultati
a dir poco straordinari tant'è che nel
nostro paese oggi la resa di frumento
per eta lo ha supera le 5 tonnellate
e questi sono alcuni dati in ordine
sparso su cosa ha significato questa
rivoluzione
e quanto sono aumentate le cure e le
chilocalorie a disposizione e
soprattutto quanto in percentuale è
stato l'aumento del cibo a nostra
disposizione
e quanto soprattutto servirebbe senza
sostanze chimiche senza questa
tecnologia per ottenere gli stessi
risultati ovvero 3 miliardi di ettari
pari a due americhe del sud
ora va detto senza ipocrisia che un
conto è ecco la pancia piena noi
occidentali ci possiamo permettere di
acquistare cibo anche a cifre
incredibili sperando più o meno che sia
salutare e che sia ai abbiano un impatto
minore sull'ambiente un altro conto e
sfamare il pianeta
tant'è che la tanto agognata e sperata
anche da chi parla agricoltura biologica
purtroppo a delle rese minori anche in
maniera molto importante anche del 40
per cento in meno a tra slide
interessante in questo senso è come
anche quella
lo si sa che è cresciuta nel nel corso
della nostra storia abbia reso la
crescita democratica demografica scusate
esplosiva solo dalla meta circa del del
secolo scorso
attenzione non sto dicendo che sono
tutte rose e fiori anzi noi siamo di
fatto vittime del nostro stesso successo
con oltre 7 miliardi di persone sul
pianeta ai problemi sono veramente
giganteschi fra l'altro all'agricoltura
dobbiamo il 14 per cento delle intere
emissioni di granda di gas serra
nell'atmosfera
dobbiamo il 70 per cento del consumo di
acqua dolce e bello 80 per cento della
deforestazione
senza scordare per esempio la
desertificazione e l'acidificazione
degli oceani dovuti alle sostanze
soprattutto azotate che vengono
riversate nei mari
se teniamo anche conto che con le
attuali ritmi di consumo abbiamo bisogno
di un pianeta e mezzo per soddisfare i
bisogni e che le risorse ovviamente del
nostro paese sono tutt'altro che
infinite servono delle soluzioni
le soluzioni possono venire secondo non
solo il sottoscritto dalla dalla
tecnologia perché abbiamo visto che di
fatto la l'agricoltura e tecnologia per
esempio possono venire dall agricoltura
di precisione possono venire da i droni
per esempio i droni li conosciamo sempre
purtroppo in scenari di guerra qua per
lo meno solo per
per la vita possiamo usare sensoristica
che ci aiuta anche nel ottimizzare le
risorse e soprattutto anche dalla dalla
chimica verde ma anche da un tabù che
spesso e volentieri viene visto solo
dagli occhi critici di tutti noi anche
della della vi presento il famosissimo
la famosissima fragola pesce la
conoscete tutti è su tutti i giornali
spesso viene fuori con con come
argomento contro gli ogm
c'è un piccolo particolare questa
fragola non esiste è di fatto una
demonizzazione del dl degli ogm non sto
qui a spiegarvi vorrei anzi stimolarli a
con occhi obiettivi a farvi un'idea di
come gli ogm possono essere davvero una
risorsa per l'ambiente e per la
sostenibilità voglio finire
raccontandovi una storia una storia che
parte diverse centinaia di migliaia di
anni fa e che vede protagonisti due
piante di generi completamente diversi
queste piante a un certo punto decidono
di unirsi e la cosa strana è che a
differenza della stragrande maggioranza
degli esseri viventi noi inclusi che
prendiamo metà del patrimonio genetico
da un genitore e l'altra metà dall'altro
questa eredita l'intero patrimonio
genetico dai due genitori
andiamo avanti con la pianta che per
selezione umana diventa il farro quello
era il farro selvatico alimenta il farro
coltivato molto caro ai gizzi e romani
che ci facevano birra e pane non è
finita qua perché il ritroviamo non
finisce qua 8 mila anni fa
ritroviamo il nostro farro coltivato che
decide di unirsi un'altra volta con una
pianta di un genere non una specie
diversa ma addirittura un genere di
nuovo un genere diverso e da
luogo al farro spelta farlo spelta
eredita anche lui l'intero patrimonio
genetico dei due genitori per selezione
poi arriviamo selezione umana arriviamo
al grano il grano tenero con il quale
facciamo pane e pizza ebbene il grano
tenero è una delle piante se non la
pianta più coltivata a livello globale è
un mostro genetico trans genetico
addirittura che si è incrociato due
volte con generi completamente diversi
a tre coppie di cromosomi rispetto a una
pianta normale a 95 mila geni un vero e
proprio mostro genetico la domanda è se
uscisse una pianta del genere da un
laboratorio del genere come la
l'accoglieremo che differenza c'è fra
una pianta così è una pianta ottenuta il
laboratorio attenzione
noi siamo sempre combattuti fra due
forze uguali opposte la curiosità e la
paura che fanno sì che di volta in volta
si evolva o ci si fermi a qualcosa di
diciamo che canyon che non ci fa
evolvere questo questo film lo abbiamo
visto tante volte nella corso della
nostra storia
tant'è che i primi libri di venivano
nascosti dai dagli agricoltori perché
ritenuti innaturali e frutto di
sacrilegio
tant'è che il bardo il grande william
shakespeare nel racconto d'inverno fa
scagliare il suo personaggio perdita
contro un mazzo di garofani screziati
quindi ibridi facendoli di definire
figli bastardi della natura vi ringrazio